[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm from Bhd here and
welcome to your first look and hands-on
of the freshly revealed iPhones for 2018
and 2019 it's now all finally revealed
or more like confirmed of what the leaks
told us we were gonna get but it's
really nice to actually have the things
in person or officially official so we
got the iPhone 10s
the 10s Max and the iPhone 10 R so this
video is just gonna be all about the
iPhone 10s and 10's max and we're gonna
do a separate video diving into the 10r
cuz I think it's actually worth another
look until then is everything you need
to know about those two phones so okay
iPhone 10s has the same 5.8 inch display
slightly tweaked but same sizes before
and the 10s max has a gigantic 6.5 inch
display it is a huge phone but yet it's
in the footprint that's roughly the same
size as something like the Galaxy Note 9
thanks to the bezels being so thin so
two very different sized phones here and
then the new colors were confirmed as
well so same exact silver as the iPhone
10 last year same exact Space Gray as
last year but then the new color for the
S is this gold so it looks pretty classy
I guess I personally probably wouldn't
get it but there is only one way to tell
on the outside that you have the new
iPhone and that's by getting the gold
one so you do you and it's gonna be
shiny and fingerprint T either way so
basically the 10 s is just the same size
as the current iPhone 10 but it's really
it's a classic Apple s update like we've
seen in the iPhone before it's a spec
bump some internal changes but nothing
drastic and no new design so the biggest
spec difference that you're getting here
is its rocking the new a12 Bionic chip
it's the first seven nanometer chip
versus the 10 nanometer process from
last year it has nearly 7 billion
transistors all of this basically
translates to it'll be a bit faster you
know they dropped a couple quotes like
it'll be maybe 30% faster but you'll
notice it in things like launching apps
and opening and closing the keyboard and
transition animations and things like
that but basically that's definitely
something we're going to have to test
and see for the full review basically
what I can be sure of is it will be even
faster same amount of RAM
as far as we can tell and I think the
other big internal upgrade for this
phone is the camera so that 10s and 10's
max both have the same new cameras so a
pair of 12 megapixel optically
stabilized cameras the primary one being
f 1.8 and you get a telephoto as well
and they're combining these new cameras
and lenses with new image signal
processing on the a12 Bionic chip to
take some seriously impressive photos
now obviously the photos and stuff they
show on stage are always gonna be
awesome but the newness is in this image
processing we all know image processing
means a lot when it comes to smartphone
photography and getting good images off
these smartphone cameras like that's a
major reason why the pixel 2 has been so
good so they introduced big improvements
there there's improved HDR called smart
HDR there's better low-light sensitivity
less noise and a really impressive
portrait mode now in portrait mode you
can go in and edit portrait photos to
literally change the f-stop of the
simulated bokeh and its really good
looking you can see the little lights in
the background of the photos changing
their blur level and it's not just
getting more or less blurry like
straight up there actually seems to be
like a directional blur based on how far
it is from the middle of the center of
the subject I was really impressed with
it and I can't wait to play with that
more and there's a bunch of other
smaller stuff so there's technically a
new front-facing camera still 7
megapixels but selfies will also benefit
from this new portrait mode and I'm
curious since its software based if it
will work with a software update to this
year's iPhone 10 - because even worked
with the iPhone 10 R which only has one
lens anyway I'm really into that and
then it's also now ip68 water-resistant
believe it or not last year's phone was
ip67 so we're looking at better
waterproofing you can literally wash
your phone off with water if you want to
the speakers are now louder and better
in an impressive way from what I've
heard they do a much better job with
stereo audio separation and things like
moving back and forth across the screen
and there's now dual sim support and
then face ID is supposed to get slightly
faster thanks to the a12 Bionic but
probably not drastically and there's
also now a slightly longer battery life
literally 30 minutes longer on the 10s
and 90 minutes longer on the 10s max I
got to find out the capacities don't
really know those yet but they're not
drastically bigger but hey that
is better I'll take that and then last
but not least the new prices it's going
to start again at $9.99 for the 10s and
1099 for the 10s max so uh that got a
lot of us thinking like is that enough
of a change it's just a big enough
upgrade for some people honestly it's
not a most buy for the most people
especially if you have an iPhone 10 I
think the the biggest difference you're
gonna get is if you go with the bigger
phone the 10s max but that thing's gonna
be expensive the 512 gig is gonna be
1449 like that's the world we live in
now but if you already have an iPhone 10
this isn't some huge must-have upgrade
it's the classic again the classic s
upgrade Apple does with the iPhone and I
got no problem with that
between a smaller and larger I'm
definitely more into the larger phone
that's just me but still no design
changes same camera bulge on the back
same stainless steel and glass materials
all around the notch didn't get smaller
or anything the bezels didn't shrink
although the notch might feel a little
bit smaller on the bigger phone no 120
Hertz display no Apple pencil support
it's just just too refined upgrade and a
new color I'll have to see if it's
worthy or not pretty soon as we work
towards the for review but my gut
feeling honestly is I'm thinking that
iPhone 10 R might be the real hit this
year for Apple it's a bit different like
I said I have a whole video on that in
the works right now that's right two
videos in one day so definitely stay
tuned for that but I'll link to it when
it's live until then this has been the
iPhone 10s and 10's max thank you for
watching and I'll talk to guys the next
one peace